be sure to come out to New York
comic-con there you can hang out with
myself and the rest of the guys of the
weekly poll and talk to us directly so
continuing my series on comic book
concepts what I want to do here is have
a discussion about the optic beams of
Cyclops now it is original appearance
the optic beams of Cyclops were not
given any real explanation of how they
worked or what they were composed up
aside from the simple offering of
uncanny x-men number 43 which stated
that he was capable of shooting a
concussive force from his eyes and did
so by absorbing sunlight and other forms
of energy whether or not this was due to
the fact that Jack Kirby and Stan Lee
intended to emphasize the nature of
their characters over their powers is
unknown but because the early stories
were less than favorable and sold low
relative to the rest of Marvel's lineup
it would stand to reason that Marvel was
simply trying to keep the title of flow
without expanding too much on existing
information as a result the first tried
and true information about the origin of
his optic beams and how they emerged
came with x-men origins Cyclops in 2010
from Stewart Moore by way of both Chris
Claremont and Howard Mackie and what I
mean here is that coming out of the
conclusion of the Dark Phoenix saga in
the first death of Jean Grey
because Claremont had spent a majority
of the issues expanding on both Jean
Grey and the Sommers line the Phoenix
and Dark Phoenix saga saw Claremont
reintroducing the character of
Christopher summers as the father of
Cyclops as well as retconning the
entirety of Cyclops his backstory in
order to fit in with Claremont vision of
the series however with Claremont
glossing over the reason for why Cyclops
his powers were activated where fans
took the mention of a childhood trauma
as absolute fat owing to Claremont being
the sole x-men writer with no
information forthcoming in 1999 during
astonishing x-men vol 2 Howard Mackie
rehashed Claremont's information with
very little expansion the serving is
part of the 12 crossover event which
centered on apocalypse capturing 12
mutants who according to the
precognitive mutant destiny would allow
apocalypse to remake the universe
astonishing x-men vol 2 function as a
three-issue limited run during the 12th
lead up and saw Professor Xavier
disbanding the x-men
while the 12 would reveal that this was
done in Xavier effort to root out an
imposter who turned out to be a scroll
masquerading as Wolverine because Marvel
sought to capitalize on the release of
x-men origins Wolverine the x-men
origins line of
comics quite literally consolidated all
existing information on the x-men
characters providing a bit of reworking
for the modern reader what we're told is
that after the plainest cyclopses
parents was attacked by a scout ship of
the Shiar empire leading to Scott and
his brother havoc escaping with a
parachute during the landing Cyclops
that hit his head while his powers
didn't immediately manifest instead
Scott experiences symptoms of a headache
including slight nausea and irritation
however with a federal government homing
in on the signal of the Shiar vessel and
tracing it to its source Scott and Alex
were discovered leading to the two of
them being separated and placed in
foster care were this tied into the
origin of Cyclops regarding mr. settlers
experiments at some point following his
17th birthday his optic beam suddenly
manifested blowing a hole in the wall of
the orphanage after which he escaped and
almost immediately ran into Charles
Xavier
now following deaths and wrapping back
around to the original series as it had
been written by Stan Lee and Jack Rudy
the early depictions of his optic beams
were largely weak in that his optic
blasts four capable of knocking powerful
foes back while this remained the
standard during both the runs of stanley
and roy thomas during the era of chris
claremont the object means the Cyclops
were expanded on in great detail and
covered in various stories over the
course of uncanny x-men issues 12 124
144 152 and 170 among others during his
17 years on the title clammin
established that instead of simply
omitting a constant flow of energy
cyclopses beams could be adjusted in
both width and intensity allowing for a
more spread out blast as well as being
confined to a singular beam allowing for
a more concentrated blast in addition to
this with x-men manifest destiny
centering on the team shifting their
headquarters from Westchester to San
Francisco as part of the story writer
Mike Harry established that cyclopses
eyes are portals to another dimension
filled with energy tying into
Claremont's writing this meant that the
intensity of cyclases blasts were
limited to the amount of energy that can
escape through his eyes as well as the
calibration of its visor to this end
Cyclops is not affected by its own
energy blast by either impact or recoil
and the blasts themselves do not
actually emit heat now whether this is a
result of his own physiology is a
question that I don't have the answer to
but I think I've heard it mentioned that
the inside of his eyelids function as a
mirror of sorts keeping the energies
from blasting through his eyelids which
explains why the object
disappear when its eyes are closed Netta
sidetrack for a second and wind back to
the visor of cyclops this artifact is by
the crutch and a saviour to his optic
glass designed by charles xavier
following his first encounter with scott
divisors exterior is composed of a
thermoplastic polymer capable of
withstanding temperatures up to 221
degrees Fahrenheit within the visor wes
a series of ruby quartz plates designed
to disrupt the optic glass of Cyclops
and are operated using twin motors
controlled by a pressure switch with a
plates moving in an upward direction
allowing the beans to pass through based
on the pressure of cyclopses finger
meaning that the harder he presses the
more the plates open however the visor
itself does have a redundant system and
that with the plates remaining in a
closed position unless the switch is
activated should the visor be damaged
Cyclops can keep it on without fear of
his optic beams blasting through
furthermore while the switch of the
visor itself was originally used as
Scouts primary method of using his beams
as technology progressed his suit was
outfitted with pressure switches in the
thumbs allowing him to activate the
visor without actually touching it
that's Ned and getting back to his optic
beams with the late 80s and early 90s a
marvel comic's enter a high-octane and
fast-paced era of storytelling the x-men
like all of models titles were adjusted
to reflect this change as a result and
under the writing of Louis Simonson
following the launch of x-factor the
intensity of cyclopses optic beams was
upgraded to include the capability of
slicing mountains in half and piercing
the hoax skin as well as focusing itself
into a beam concentrated enough to punch
a hole through most any material with
the exception of adamantium guru metal
the organic metal skin of Colossus and
Captain America's shield at the same
time the optic beams of Cyclops do come
with several drawbacks covered in Howard
Mackey's astonishing x-men with a late
90s saw Marvel attending to revamp some
of their characters in an effort to
drive sales from new concepts
Howard Mackie established the cyclopses
inability to control his optic beams was
entirely psychological and that through
the use of advisor he had literally come
to believe that control of the beams was
beyond his ability where this allowed
Mackie to begin moving Cyclops in the
direction of being able to function
without Ruby courts because the visor
was as much an intricate part of his
character if not a staple he was quickly
restored to the status quo the
furthermore in addition to the materials
of adamantium guru metal the organic
metal skin of Colossus
Captain America shield being able to
withstand his blast certain mutants also
possess powers or modifications that
hinder the power of cyclopses beams
where apocalypse havoc and Vulcan all
stand as the most commonly cited
examples due to apocalypses conflicts in
the x-men cartoon show of the 90s havoc
being the brother of Cyclops and the to
being able to negate each other's powers
as well as well can being able to
control all forms of energy including
Cyclops as object beams magneto presents
a challenge as well due to his control
over magnetism allowing him to invoke
the electromagnetic spectrum to diffuse
cyclopses blasts in addition to this
because the energy of Cyclops glass is
part and parcel to himself and that it
provides a portion of sustenance if he
were to use the totality of his energy
it could potentially be fatal however as
was stated during the Civil War conflict
Cyclops has never actually used the full
offering of energy available to him as
far as I'm aware the closest cyclops has
ever come to cutting loose and his
capacity came during x-men adventures
number 9 in 1993 when he blasted the
juggernaut with enough energy to destroy
a small planet but had no effect with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you hit the
subscribe button so you can follow with
my comic book concept series every
Friday and I will catch you guys on it
peace